conservatives are celebrating as a
transvestite YouTube Star says that the
leftist gender ideologues have gone too
far
I didn't tell all the other I
think what other do they in
them yeah and all that extra that we
added during the pandemics everyone was
so bored on their houses they just
started to make up more more stuff yeah
that's where the conservatives like me
because I'm just real yeah you do have a
conservative IPM your trans your male or
your female
and you're standing on that so mad when
I say that how are you with they what
the does that mean as stupid as
what it is yeah but you need someone
like me that looks like me to say it
because if you say it it turns into your
homophobic you hate trans people you
hate gays and it's just how you feel you
don't hate anyone you just think it's
stupid
Jack guy is Jeffrey steininger goes by
the stage name Jeffrey Starr and a
number of conservatives a fairly
prominent conservatives are lauding him
for saying enough is enough with the
non-binary they them gender pronouns and
all I can think is
this is how conservatives always lose
this is the new line this is the new
Overton window of acceptable political
discourse in 2023 the line is
transgenderism is fine but non-binary is
crazy yeah you tell them Jeffrey
Democrats they're the real transphobes
good grief
this is what always happens
50 years ago conservatives said
okay feminism is fine but homosexuality
is crazy then 30 years ago conservatives
said okay homosexuality is fine but gay
marriage is crazy then 10 years ago
conservatives said okay gay marriage is
fine but transgenderism is crazy and now
in the year of Our Lord 2023
conservatives are saying
you know it okay transgenderism's fine
but this non-binary stuff is crazy
they're saying transgenderism is fine
but wait until they turn 18 to chop them
up
transgenderism is fine but wait until
they turn nine to teach them about it in
school
that's in one of the most conservative
States on this issue they say wait till
eight once they turn nine then you can
talk about it this is how we lose
because we fail to understand what the
left understands which is that if you
accept the left's basic premises those
premises are eventually going to be
taken to their logical conclusions if
you accept the premise in this case that
men and women are basically the same you
can start that out in the 70s you can
start that out with feminism you are
going to end up here you can try to slow
it down a little bit
you can try in vain to push pause on the
unfolding of history based on certain
premises but you're never going to stop
it you're certainly never going to stop
it at transgenderism is fine but
non-binary is crazy in fact the guy who
articulated that view
too much conservative Fanfare is already
walking it back
anyone that is trying to make it seem
like I said that non-binary people don't
exist I never said that record this
right now never said it you're putting
words in my mouth I said I don't like
the pronouns and I don't agree with them
I never said that they don't exist
I'm a freak I'm a part of the lgbtq
community
I'm pansexual I'm bisexual whatever the
you want to call me I don't like
labels I like guys I like girls I like
sleeping with both but I love men
whatever you think that it that means to
you I don't care label it however you
want but don't put words in my mouth I
do not agree with a few things I'm old
school but this new all these 30 Terms
girl stop stop complicating everything
just chill take a hit relax and don't
put words in my mouth
there he is Jeffree Star Mr Conservative
that's the most conservative guy in
America 30 years from now
I'm only half joking 30 years from now
it's going to be 20 53 we're gonna say
man you remember that far right winger
Jeffree Star that's what's going to
happen if the American right doesn't
wake up and start offering people
something other than just the leftism of
10 years ago the rest of the show
continues now you do not want to miss it
you can go to dailywear.com
for two months free on all annual plans
we'll see you over there
[Music]
thank you